[eerie cackling]
Hello, viewer.
Welcome to our first ever Halloween Week.
Ugh!
Oh, wow, look at that.
Ugh, the witch's hair. And, oh, that nose.
Oh, is that prosthetics or CGI?
I haven't even been to make-up yet.
Welcome to The Great British Baking Show.
Shall I go and look for another job now?
Yes. [scoffs]
[Matt] This time…
-[spookily] Whoo!
-…it's Halloween Week…
Hold your breath.
[Matt] With a spine-chilling signature…
This witch has eyeliner problem.
-I'm scared.
-[mimics whirring]
…that's all about apples.
It's like a cauldron.
Don't want to ruin my make-up.
Goodness.
[Matt] A terrifying technical…
So sticky.
…that has the bakers feeling the heat.
-[Abdul] Is this on fire?
-Ah, too much!
[Abdul] No, they're all burning.
Wow!
[Matt] And a showstopper…
Don't know whether to be shocked
or turned on. Don't know what's going on.
[Maxy] It's falling apart.
[Matt] …that's sure to cause nightmares.
-[Maxy] It's not going to hang.
-Just breathe, breathe.
[sniffles]
[opening theme music playing]
[in spooky voice] Happy Halloween!
I'm excited about this week. Gives us
more opportunity to be more creative.
The more revolting, the better, you know.
You know, I think my bakes are quite cute,
so they won't frighten them.
If I get put out and I need to do
my leaving speech in this shirt,
I'll be well annoyed.
Bakers, welcome back to the tent
for Halloween Week.
Yes!
How do you like them apples?
-[chuckles]
-Well, quite a lot, I hope.
Because for your signature challenge,
the judges would like you each to bake
an exquisitely decorated apple cake.
Apples have been intertwined
with Halloween throughout history.
How so, Noel?
In the olden days,
peasants were put in a bucket
and a giant apple would turn up
and try and pull them out with its teeth.
-Been reading books upside down again?
-Possibly.
[Matt] You can use
any type of sponge you like,
but your hero ingredient
must be fresh apple.
You have two spooky hours. On your marks.
-Get set…
-Boo!
I love Halloween, love trick-or-treating
love dressing up.
It's an opportunity to be a big kid again.
[imitates whirring]
This is Halloween Week. [chuckles]
[Paul] Obviously, Halloween,
we think of dunking apples, et cetera.
We want to celebrate the apple.
We want the apple
to be the hero in this cake.
That is mad how many apples we've got.
Need to stick some spices in there,
so cinnamons sticks.
[Prue] Things like cinnamon
go beautifully with apples.
But the bakers have to be careful
because we want
the dominant flavour to be apple.
[Paul] Ultimately, we want an apple cake,
not, and I stress, not an apple pudding,
trifle, or an apple dessert.
I really wanna see
at the end of this challenge
an apple cake that A, looks amazing,
and B, tastes of apples.
-[Prue] Hi, Janusz.
-Janusz! Happy Halloween.
Happy Halloween.
I've decided to dress as Noel,
but I'm gonna call myself "Not Fielding".
[laughter]
So I'm baking in heels today.
[Noel] Look at those. [whistles]
-[Prue] I like the eye make-up too.
-Thank you.
-Big shout to Syabira. She's done it.
-[laughter]
Tell us about your cake.
What are you doing?
I've decided to make something
my mum would make when I was a child.
[Matt] Janusz's mum's apple cake
celebrates two varieties.
Sharp Cox's flavour the sponge
and sweet Pinks in the buttercream,
both spiced to bring Halloween heat.
I'm putting ginger, cinnamon,
cloves, nutmeg and allspice.
I want my spices to be recognisable,
but not to kill the apple.
-[Paul] Good luck.
-Thank you very much.
This is chilli. It's Halloween,
you need something spicy.
[Matt] After failing to impress
with flavour last week,
Syabira plans to wow with a cake inspired
by her favourite Malaysian dessert.
Asam Boi, which is
a sour plum and also chilli.
So I'm actually trying
to bring that flavour together.
[Matt] She'll spread sour plum
and chilli cream cheese icing
and Bramley apple crumble
between layers of apple sponge
to create a giant apple-shaped cake.
It's going to be red,
and then it has witch eyes and a hat--
-[Prue] Witch's hat?
-Oh, wow.
This is a very ambitious thing.
Are you going to finish it in time?
-Yes.
-[Paul] Good luck.
Bonkers. Sounds like you,
it's gonna be great.
-Good luck. Witchy apple.
-[Syabira chuckles]
[Noel] While Syabira's putting on
a spooky spectacle…
-[spookily] Whoo!
-[chuckles]
Whoo! Did I scare you?
-Yes.
-[Matt] Oh, good.
[Noel] …Maxy's apple cake
is somewhat more traditional.
It's apple and walnuts
with cream cheese frosting.
Is that cream cheese frosting
or is it "scream" cheese frosting?
[Noel] Her classic cake features
layers of spiced apple and walnut sponge
filled with cream cheese frosting,
apple puree and salted caramel,
elegantly decorated
with fresh apple and whole walnuts.
-[Matt] I don't love walnuts.
-[Maxy] Why?
Looks like monkey brain.
[Maxy] Don't think it's a bad thing.
-[Matt] You like eating brains?
-No, no.
-It's a bit Halloween-y.
-[laughs]
[Sandro] I am using Bramley apples.
When it's cooked, I think it tastes
more apple than any other apple.
[Matt] Whatever variety the bakers choose…
[Syabira] I have
a Granny Smith and Pink apple,
so it has a sourness to it
and a sweetness.
[Matt] …how it's incorporated is critical
to achieving the perfectly even
distribution that judges expect.
[Abdul] I'm going for chunks,
and of course if I grate
some of them, they will kind of melt.
Initially, I wanted to
chop my apples and put 'em in.
But grating them releases the flavour.
[Dawn] This is the Granny Smith
going all the way through the cake.
It's very light, this cake.
So the apples have a tendency
to end up at the bottom.
[Noel] Dawn will attempt
to suspend her sliced apple
within a fragile, fat-free
sharlotka whisked sponge,
and her toffee apple decorations
will be soaked in blood orange juice
for extra creepy colour.
[Matt] Are you a big Halloween fan?
-I do like Halloween. Yes. It's good.
-Yeah.
-What do you do for Halloween?
-Creepy baking, yeah.
-And what--
-Matt, what are you doing?
Whoa! [laughing]
Oh, he's scary enough anyway.
He doesn't need to creep around.
I'm trying to be as speedy as possible
because my sponges bake for 40 minutes,
which is quite a while.
[Matt] The addition
of fresh fruit to their batter
increases the moisture content,
meaning a longer bake.
Er, the clock's ticking.
[Matt] The quicker
they can get them in the oven,
the more time their sponges
will have to cool.
I've got a broken wing.
I can't use this arm.
[Dawn] Right, going in now.
[Matt] Any attempt to assemble
and decorate when warm
could result in catastrophe.
The cakes are in for about 40 minutes.
[Maxy] Right on time.
[Matt] But Kevin's cake
isn't ready to bake.
I'm making a streusel cake,
so each sponge will have
chunks of apple and streusel on top.
Actually a lot to do
before I get it in the oven.
[Noel] Kevin will fill
his streusel topped sponges
with cream cheese frosting
and top his cake
with apples poached in spiced cider
and caramel shards.
[Prue] It sounds so delicious.
Crunchy streusel and this sponge--
[Noel] We should start a band
called The Crunchy Streusels.
Ladies and gentlemen,
The Crunchy Streusels.
Yeah, it feels like a jazz trio.
[laughter]
[mimics playing trumpet]
[in spooky voice] Bakers,
you are halfway through.
Sorry, I'm late.
Oh, right, I see what's going on.
Fine.
[in normal voice] I thought this was Noel.
[laughs]
[Kevin] A bit behind. Ah.
[vocalises]
That's the sponges in,
they'll get 30 minutes.
So I just hope I've got time to decorate.
[Matt] While Kevin plays catch-up,
the rest of the bakers press on
with fillings and toppings.
[Janusz] Apple-spiced buttercream.
It's like a cauldron.
Don't want to ruin my make-up.
[Matt] Not only must
every element work in harmony…
I really love caramel with apple cake.
…it's crucial nothing
overpowers the flavour of their apple.
Sour plum and chilli. It's a risky
business, putting flavourings.
[Sandro] Wicked.
[Noel] But in his bid for
a second straight Star Baker crown…
[Sandro] I'm using cinnamon whisky.
[Noel] …it's a risk Sandro's embracing.
These are just gonna stick in the sponge.
[Matt] He'll cover his cake
with caramel glaze, spiced apple
and walnut crumble
and, in case his whisky transfusion
isn't terrifying enough,
a crystal sugar skull
will sit glaring from the top.
-Is this my death mask?
-And then this-- [chuckles]
This is your skull.
I'm worried about the weight
of that skull.
It'll be fine.
I'm not adding any more to it.
[Noel] Abdul is also
going all out with his decorations.
So I'm making basically a bonfire cake.
Logs are gonna be made
out of apple dipped in chocolate.
And caramel shards represent fire.
[Noel] Hoping to set
the judges' hearts alight,
his bonfire cakes contain
apple and almond sponge,
cream cheese frosting and almond streusel,
all wrapped in a delicate
piped chocolate collar.
Abdul, you've come as what? Scary NASA?
Er, yes. [chuckles] I'm a rogue astronaut.
What's your favourite costume?
-If I really wanna scare people…
-Mmm-hmm.
…and make them unnerved,
-I would dress as Paul Hollywood.
-[chuckles]
[Janusz] They look ready.
[Syabira] Okay. Go.
You can't hear any sound of it cooking.
It's cooked.
[Matt] The quicker
the cakes are out of the oven…
-I will cool it for 15 minutes.
-[timer beeping]
…the longer they'll have
to chill before assembly starts.
Waiting for them to cool
to start working on them.
[Matt] But Kevin's are still baking.
The sponges need to be completely cool,
otherwise the icing will
just melt out the sides.
[eerie cackling]
Bakers, you have half an hour left.
[exhales]
You've got a spider in your hair.
-Really?
-Yeah. I'll just get it out.
-Thanks.
-There you go.
[Janusz] Righty-ho, should be ready.
Hold your breath.
It's very light, this cake.
It's a bit broken there.
I am frosting it.
[Kevin] The cake's out.
Not sure if they'll be cool enough.
[Sandro] Caramel glaze.
[Syabira] This is apple crumble filling
and sponge.
[Dawn] This is incredibly fragile.
[in sing-song voice] I don't think
it's gonna be cold enough.
Are you a big trick-or-treater?
-Of course.
-Who do you like to dress up as?
[whispering] A pregnant nun.
A pregnant nun?
That is correct.
[Matt] Do you get
a lot of interest from guys?
Yeah, especially from monks.
[laughing]
[Syabira] The is
the Halloween Witch Apple.
I can't go back now.
Either they like it or they don't.
How long, really, can I get away with
leaving for icing?
Maybe five minutes.
Bakers, you have five minutes left.
Maybe I can do it
in three minutes. [chuckles]
[Dawn] Dipping apples
very quickly in caramel.
Got our caramel as well, going on the top.
[Abdul] Chocolate trees.
You have to handle it delicately
or it can break apart.
Oh! Man down.
I don't know how to make it look scarier.
Why am I always doing this
in the last minutes?
Oops, almost dropping an orange
onto my cake. [laughs]
[Janusz] That is my chocolate drip.
This is my skull. I frickin' like it.
[Kevin] It's so stressful.
How are we doing for time?
One minute left.
[Kevin] Oh, man alive.
This witch has eyeliner problem.
It's just not even.
Definitely learn not to rush.
You want it to look nice and neat.
[Sandro] Add the finesse.
[nervously] Ah.
[Abdul] I'm happy.
Bakers, your time is up.
[snaps fingers]
Looking around the room,
I can see really lovely cakes
and it's like, "Ah, is mine too simple?"
So good!
-[Abdul] I didn't make enough trees.
-[Dawn] Oh, they're lovely, though.
Even that wee heat is enough
to melt the icing.
[eerie whistling]
[Noel] The bakers' apple cakes now
face the judgement of Paul and Prue.
-[Prue] Hello, Sandro.
-Hello.
Let's take that off for a second.
I mean, I know it's Halloween,
but I really think that skull
ruins your cake.
Oh, really? Okay.
[Prue] It's such a beautiful shape
and you plonk a great big skull on top.
-[Paul] What's in this?
-[Sandro] Cinnamon whisky.
That's really got whisky.
Even for me,
I don't think I'd put any more in.
-Maybe I will. Why not?
-[all laughing]
Why change the habit of a lifetime?
[Sandro] I made a spiced apple sponge.
It's a lovely, moist sponge.
-[Paul] An amazing spice cake pudding.
-[Prue] It is.
-But apple? Not really.
-No?
-For me, it's not apple-y enough.
-[Sandro] Okay.
Well, I can see it's a bonfire.
[laughter]
I like the trees. It's quite effective.
[Prue] But the caramel shards
are a bit thick.
Okay. I put grated apples in there
and almond streusel.
-Good streusel, good texture.
-I think it's a really good cake.
You have the whole apples in there,
which do taste of apple.
With actually a beautifully moist sponge.
-I think you did really well.
-Thank you.
The sponges are made with Cox apples,
and then the buttercream
is Pink apples with spices.
I'm not getting any apple flavour.
I am getting the spices.
It's a shame,
I think the sponge is lovely.
And the texture
of the buttercream is lovely.
I love the idea of the puree.
But again, the spices have killed it.
So if this was a spice cake challenge,
you'd win it.
-Misses the brief.
-[Paul] Yeah.
Well, misses the apple.
-Yeah.
-[laughter]
-Thank you, Noel.
-Thank you.
[Paul] Er… Janusz.
[Dawn] It's a very light sponge.
I put some toffee apples
and some whipped cream on top, and it…
-Dropped?
-…sunk a bit, yes.
-I'd say quite a bit.
-Quite a lot.
[Prue] How did you put the apple in here?
[Dawn] I put a layer of apple,
another layer of apple to distribute it.
-I'm not getting a lot of apple.
-Okay.
Got it down the bottom. I actually
really like the apple on the top.
[laughter]
[Prue] Toffee apples are so powerful.
They make the rest
of the cake rather dull.
Okay.
-It does look a bit of a mess.
-It promised a lot.
[Kevin chuckling]
[Paul] You did it when it was warm.
That's the reaction between cream cheese
and the hot cake,
and it just pours out like lava.
Yeah, yeah.
[Prue] So tell us about your apple cake.
[Kevin] Well, it's an apple streusel cake
flavoured with almond.
Apples are beautiful in it
with the almond, especially with cream.
-Erm…
-[chuckling] Yeah.
It tastes amazing.
It's a bit like a trifle.
-Just delicious, isn't it?
-We wanted a cake, not a pudding.
[chuckles]
[Paul] If I'd walked into a room
and saw that, I'd know that was your cake.
It's got Maxy written all over it.
-It is neat as a pin.
-[Prue] I love the decoration on the top,
-the little apple strips.
-Thank you.
So, I have made a apple and walnut cake
and I've topped the top player
with some caramel.
[Prue] That's a really good cake.
-Really good.
-Thank you.
The apple comes through beautifully.
Walnut, is that texture at the end.
I think you've
done the apple justice actually.
-Well done.
-Oh, my God. Thank you.
-[applause]
-Thank you so much.
-[Paul] Thank you.
-[Prue] Well done, Maxy.
-[whispering] Well done.
-Thank you.
[Paul] I'm not sure about the face,
-it's gone all over the place, hasn't it?
-[Prue] I love the face.
I mean, for heaven's sake, it's a witch.
Of course she can be crooked.
-It has eyeliner problem today.
-[Paul] Yeah.
-[Syabira] It's a hot day.
-[laughter]
This is my favourite snack
of apples, sour plum and chilli.
I love it. Really powerful flavours.
Sour plum is perfect.
-That cake is beautiful.
-[Prue] It's so light.
I was gonna say I didn't get the chilli.
It's just come in.
I'm not sure about the face.
But nevertheless…
-Oh, thank you. [chuckling]
-I'm really glad. You deserve that.
Chilli is the thing that gets me.
It's a real triumph. Flavour's back.
-Well done.
-Thank you.
I'm very pleased. First, the handshake,
and they said my flavour's back!
[chuckling]
I just feel super, super happy.
I'm over the moon.
[Maxy and Syabira mumbling excitedly]
I'm pleased for Maxy and Syabira.
Syabira's first handshake.
It's just a shame.
Apart from the obvious construction issue,
they said a lot of nice things about it,
which was really sweet of them.
[Dawn] I don't think it was
a disastrous judging,
but I'm really worried that at this stage,
you really need to nail it, and I didn't.
And my technicals
have been very up-and-down,
so I've got to throw everything at this.
[Noel] While the bakers were able
to practise their signatures,
their next challenge is a total mystery.
Bakers, it's time for your
Halloween technical challenge,
which, today, has been set by Paul.
Paul, any words of advice?
But please say them
in your scariest voice.
-[in normal voice] There are two--
-[screams] It's too scary! [whimpers]
There are two very distinctive textures
you have to get right in this recipe.
And allow time for setting.
You have to figure that one out yourself.
As ever, the technical challenge
will be judged blind,
so we're gonna have to ask
Freddy Prue-ger and Paul-tergeist
to leave the tent.
For your technical challenge,
Paul would like you each
to make eight s'mores.
The kind of sweet treat
you might have round a campfire
while telling scary stories.
Your s'mores should have
a gooey toasted marshmallow.
And a creamy dark chocolate ganache
sandwiched between two digestive biscuits.
No more instructions, please,
it's too scary!
-[Noel] You okay?
-I'm fine.
I'll tell them how long they've got.
-You're going to be fine?
-Yeah.
You have two hours.
-[Matt] On your marks.
-Get set--
[shrieks]
Bake?
Goodness.
[Sandro] S'mores.
[emphasises] S'mores. S'mores.
-Alrighty.
-[Kevin] S'mores.
They're a distinctly American confection.
I've never had one,
but seen it in the movies.
I've never made
marshmallows or digestives.
[chuckling] I'm completely lost!
So, Paul, s'mores.
It's a great challenge, actually.
And the reason why I said
about the two contrasting textures
is obviously the marshmallow.
And then, the actual biscuit itself.
The biscuit's straightforward enough.
It's about rubbing
all the dry ingredients with the butter,
adding the liquid, bringing it together.
The next thing is obviously
the marshmallow,
which is basically
whipped Italian meringue.
But you gotta add gelatine.
The key thing is, once you've added
the gelatine, is leaving it to set.
Now, if they don't,
the whole thing could collapse.
We want it to be as neat as possible.
We want the chocolate
in there as well, not too much.
You don't want it flooding down the side.
But then, you want this blowtorch
around the outside of the marshmallow.
Now, they could go wrong with this
because if they add too much heat,
it's going to melt.
-So very lightly.
-And it just looks beautiful.
Ultimately, you're meant to
eat it like this.
[laughing] I don't know if I can.
You get covered in chocolate, marshmallow
and a little bit of crumbs of biscuit.
It's lovely.
-It is good.
-But, hold back.
We've got another seven to try.
First, I need to make
the biscuits' dough and chill.
[Dawn] I have made
digestive biscuits before,
but no, you just buy them.
[Kevin] I'm looking for a biscuit dough
that holds together and isn't too crumbly.
So when I roll it out,
it will still hold its shape.
-[Noel] Hello.
-Hello.
Did you get a handshake?
I did. Right hand.
I haven't washed it since then.
[Noel] Can I touch it?
-No.
-Ahh!
-I need some of that power.
-That Paul power?
What did it feel like?
I was surprised.
Did you look into his eyes
when he shook your hand?
No, I didn't,
I was just like, "Thank you."
I'm more happy because
they said my flavours is back, so…
[Noel] Wow!
[Dawn] I think this is about right.
Dough is done and I'm going to chill it.
Right. I'm going to crack on
with the marshmallow now.
Marshmallow is really
just an Italian meringue.
I'm guessing it's with gelatine.
I don't really know how to make it.
[Janusz] Whip your egg whites
up with sugar,
keep on whipping. Done.
Are you a fan of s'mores?
-I've never had a s'more.
-[Matt] Too sweet for me.
I know the sweetest thing I've ever eaten.
-Yeah.
-When I was a little kid,
my mum had sweeteners
that you put in your coffee,
-and I ate a couple of those.
-Ooh!
-All my hair fell out.
-I-- [chuckles]
[Maxy] Stiff peaks. I think we're there.
[Syabira] I need to bloom the gelatine.
[Matt] Gelatine is key
to the marshmallow's structure.
[Dawn] Let's hope this works.
[Matt] But adding it
at the right time is crucial.
[Abdul] I'm now putting
the syrup inside the meringue.
[Matt] Unless their gelatine
is dissolved completely,
the bakers could end up
with a marshmallow monstrosity.
Oh, shoot. I forgot my gelatine.
Did I forget something?
I feel like I've forgotten something.
I forgot to put gelatine in there. Damn!
I forgot to put the gelatine in.
What happens now?
I was going to put it in the syrup.
I don't know if I've ruined it.
-Hello, Dawn of the Dead.
-You all right?
Did you get a handshake?
No. Made good toffee apples apparently,
but the cake was rubbish.
Dentist's nightmare, though,
the toffee apple.
Oh, God, yeah,
that's why I've got so many fillings.
I've got fillings that go right down
my back teeth and all down one leg.
-Really? That's impressive.
-Yeah.
-Into my long toe.
-That's very good. That's very impressive.
Which is my second toe
'cause I'm an amphibian.
[Kevin] We're just about there.
Righty-ho, that's setting.
[Sandro] Looks nice and bouncy.
[Maxy] I don't know what I'm looking for.
I'm just gonna stick with it.
Next, I'm going to roll out biscuit dough.
[Janusz] Pleased with my dough.
[Kevin] We're looking for 16
of these bad boys.
[Maxy] One, two, three, four, five, six…
They're sticking to the paper.
I'll reroll it.
Oh, what a mess!
And now the stamping will be fun.
[Syabira] It's very delicate.
[Maxy] They're all different shapes,
but, you know, it'll be fine.
That one can be hidden at the bottom.
Let me bake them.
The instructions doesn't say how long.
[Abdul] Good luck, biscuits. Do me proud.
[Matt] Noel, are you okay?
-Yeah, my gerbil died.
-I'm so sorry to hear that.
I'm not bothered about that.
-It's just, he's haunting me.
-[exclaims]
Oh, hello.
Ow! Still bites.
Bakers, you are halfway through.
-What?
-Oh, my goodness.
What am I doing? Ganache, ganache.
Classic ganache is half and half, so
it's half double cream and half chocolate.
[Syabira] The ganache should be set,
not a watery ganache.
So it needs time to be in the fridge.
Oh, it's so liquidy.
Pop that in the fridge for a minute.
[Maxy] What's going on
with these biscuits?
Still looking a bit pale and squidgy.
Just a bit more.
[Sandro] Paul is going to say
it's not golden enough.
Been trying to get more to his tan,
so I'm going to give it
another two minutes.
-They look ready.
-Yeah.
[Sandro] I feel like
they are digestive-y biscuits.
These are starting to go golden round
the edges, I think that's the sweet spot.
They could have been more uniform.
[Matt] They're looking pretty good.
Have you made digestives before?
No, this is the first time.
I mean, they're so cheap.
It's like, "Hmm, I'll just go buy it."
There's your passion
as a baker coming out.
[laughs] Yes.
Bakers, you have 15 minutes left.
Oh, my goodness.
[Dawn] Panic, panic.
"Turn the marshmallow out,
cut out eight rounds of it."
[Maxy] My marshmallow's definitely wrong.
It's not as stable as it should be.
[Abdul] It's set from the outside,
but I think from the inside,
it's still very wet and sticky. Hmm.
-[chuckles] Risky.
-[sighs]
[Dawn] I'm gonna
get it done in time if it kills me.
Erm, this isn't easy.
[Kevin] So sticky.
[Sandro] Come on, baby. Get out.
[Maxy] This ain't looking too great!
-[Syabira] Chocolate.
-It's assembly time.
I'm just giving the ganache a spread.
[Sandro] I wish I set the chocolate first.
They did the right thing by cooling
theirs because mine is quite soft.
Ooh.
[Maxy] Oh, no, no.
-It's a pain in the ass to assemble.
-[Sandro] They don't like mess.
[Maxy] That one's not great.
They're just not looking uniform.
Bakers, you have one minute left.
Okay, I have to be careful now.
[Janusz] I'm looking for a golden colour.
[Abdul] Is this one on fire?
[Kevin] Doing a bit of touch up.
Ah, too much!
[Abdul] No, they're all burning.
Just, just don't start dripping.
I wish I set my ganache.
[Abdul gasps] No!
Why are you doing this to me, man?
Bakers, your time is up.
[Syabira] Not bad.
[Abdul] A mess is what this is.
Please bring your s'mores
down to the gingham table
and place them behind your photograph.
[Maxy] Thank God, it's over.
[Abdul] I think I've cooked it too much.
[Noel] Paul and Prue
are looking for eight s'mores
with crisp digestive biscuits,
silky chocolate ganache
and a beautifully toasted
marshmallow centre.
They have no idea whose are whose.
Start with this one. Straight off,
lost the definition in the biscuit.
Yeah.
[Prue] I like the biscuit.
[Paul] But the marshmallow
just melts a bit too readily.
It's more meringue than marshmallow.
-[Prue] Okay.
-[Paul] This one.
Nice bit of colour on that biscuit.
[Prue] They look nice.
I like how it's torched.
This has got much more
definition on the biscuit.
[Paul] Got a bit more chew.
-Bit more goo to the marshmallow as well.
-A little bounce.
[Paul] Moving on. Bit all over the place.
Colour looks a bit light as well.
-[Prue] Not identical, are they?
-[Paul] No.
-Bit rubbery, that biscuit.
-[Prue] Marshmallow's too soft.
-[Paul] Hmm.
-And the biscuits also slightly too soft.
[Paul] It is.
[Prue] This is definitely chocolate drips,
which we didn't intend.
No, the chocolate's gone everywhere.
All down the side.
The biscuit's all right.
It's very soft marshmallow.
It disappears almost instantly.
Erm, moving on.
The colour is perfect on the side.
And also, they all look exactly the same
and the definition is really good.
-Just that one's lost a bit.
-[Paul] Mmm.
The chocolate is the right consistency.
-[Prue] Texture's perfect.
-[Paul] It is.
[Prue] Chocolate's perfect. Neat as a pin.
This one's a bit messy.
A little bit messy.
The colour's all right on the side.
The biscuits are really nice,
but they're quite well baked, aren't they?
Any longer, and it would've been too much.
They're not the best-looking things,
but the textures are nice.
Moving on to the big issue.
[Prue] The marshmallow is a disaster,
but the biscuits look really perfect.
Hmm, biscuits are good.
The marshmallow's terrible.
That's a shame.
[Matt] Paul and Prue will rank
the s'mores from last to first place.
Okay, in seventh spot we have… this one.
Abdul, big problem with the marshmallow.
Yeah, I decimated them
with the burner. [chuckles]
-Really?
-Yes. They came out--
You just super-heated them
and they melted?
[Prue] In sixth place, we have this one.
Maxy, the texture was just
a little bit too soft.
[Matt] In fifth place is Dawn.
Sandro is fourth and Kevin third.
In second place, we have this one.
Who's that?
Janusz.
This is a really nice s'mores.
Lovely texture, just a little bit
of definition, not looking perfect.
And in first, we have this one.
[Prue] Syabira.
You were 95% there,
just one never really had the definition.
-But everything else was really nice.
-[Prue] Perfect.
Thank you.
I'm very, very happy
that it worked out well.
Although Paul say it's 95%,
it's A-plus still.
[chuckles]
[Janusz] Coming second,
it's a really good result.
And I'm really happy for Syabira
because she needed this confidence boost.
Sad life.
All I needed to do
was lightly use the burner.
But I was like…
[imitates blowtorch whooshing]
That went so-so.
Not great, not good enough.
Potentially, I'm in trouble.
The competition is just incredibly fierce.
I don't feel
in a particularly strong position
because the morning was rough,
and even coming third in the technical,
I don't think there was much in it.
So I need to have
a really good showstopper.
[Noel] Just one challenge remains
before Paul and Prue
decide who is this week's Star Baker
and whose time in the tent is up.
[Syabira] Good luck.
[Matt] Good morning, bakers.
Hope you're having a happy Halloween.
Hope you haven't been scared
by any ghosts or spooked by any spectres.
Hope you haven't been shocked
because you've seen some ghoulies.
-[snickers]
-Noel, you're looking a bit pale.
-Did you see some ghoulies?
-I did see some ghoulies and so did Prue.
-[Matt] Was this in Paul's dressing room?
-[Noel] Yes, it was.
I'm so sorry.
[Noel] Okay, bakers,
for your Halloween showstopper,
the judges would like you
to make a hanging lantern.
Think trick or treat,
think jack-o'-lantern.
And when smashed open,
must reveal an array
of sweet treats inside.
[Matt] You have four hours.
-On your marks…
-Get set…
[spookily] Bake.
Feeling good, feeling excited for today.
[Syabira] I am quite nervous
'cause it's a showstopper.
The last thing you want to do
is doing it badly.
[Kevin] Didn't have
a strong day yesterday,
so I can't do anything
short of my best work.
Any less, I'm done for.
[Paul] The bakers can have fun with this.
We want them to make a hanging lantern
out of whatever they wish.
Structurally, has to be sound,
but it's got to taste good as well.
It has to be robust enough to hang,
but fragile enough to crack it
with one bang of a rolling pin
so that sweet treats
can tumble out like a piñata.
We want at least two varieties.
[Paul] This is Halloween,
so we're expecting maybe eyeballs,
fingernails, witch's hats, noses.
I've got my "bloodberry" coulis.
[Prue] As always,
timing will be really crucial
because it'll be tricky enough to make
and bake sweet treats and the lanterns,
but then they've got to decorate them
and they have to have time
to do it exquisitely.
[Paul] I want to see Halloween
hanging in a lantern
with maybe a few
windows and a bit of light.
It's not difficult, surely.
[Paul] Morning.
-[Janusz] Good morning.
-[Prue] Hello.
Tell us about your hanging lantern.
I've decided to celebrate horror movies.
So I'm making a popcorn box
with scary decoration
and I'm going to hide
two different truffles.
Trick or treat truffles.
[Matt] Janusz's truffles will be hidden
within a popcorn box lantern
built from almond sablé biscuit
and feature a treat flavoured
with spiced pumpkin
and a trick containing
pistachio and crickets.
-Cricket?
They'll be made with cricket powder
and then with smoked whole crickets
inside to provide the crunch.
They ground down really nice.
-They're more like peppery.
-[Prue] They make quite good flour.
[Matt] Sorry, what?
-Are we just talking about insects here?
-We are. And you know what?
Insects are going to be the future
because they're easy to farm,
cheap, very ecologically sound.
And they're pretty nice as well.
It's like you're eating bacon.
Very original. I'm looking forward to it.
-Thank you.
Poor Jiminy Cricket.
-Would you like one?
-No, I would not.
[laughs]
I love scary movies.
We usually watch
scary movies all the time.
My boyfriend used to do ghost hunting,
and we always watch paranormal stuff.
We do enjoy our scary pleasure.
[giggles]
[Noel] And it's scary pleasure
Syabira is planning to serve up.
Her spider made from spiced biscuit,
will contain peanut cookie
Frankenstein fingers
and mummy shortbreads
featuring a unique flavour combination.
[Syabira] I'm making an orange shortbread
with white truffle maple syrup
cream cheese filling.
It's a little bit like a gamble,
that one is.
Are you nervous today?
-Yeah, 'cause--
-[Paul] Hold your hand out.
-[Prue] She's shaking. Good luck.
-[Syabira laughs]
-[Paul laughing]
-It's another handshake before baking.
[Prue] You just did it.
-[laughing]
-[Paul] No, you'll be fine. Enjoy.
Done really well so far,
having a good week.
Thank you. Thank you so much.
[Matt] But Syabira's spider
isn't the only
eight-legged showstopper in the tent.
My bake is called Arachna-FOMO.
As in, fear of missing out.
Because we were never allowed to
dress up as anything scary for Halloween,
like zombies or vampires.
We're Christian, so we had to
dress up as something benign.
Once I got dressed up
as a clock with a mouse running up it.
As in, "Hickory Dickory".
We've got a friend that's a Christian
and his mum sent him out trick-or-treating
dressed as Toulouse-Lautrec.
[laughs]
[Matt] Kevin's spider will be made
from orange and five-spice sugar cookie
with choux pastry legs
and marshmallow eyes.
Inside the beastie's belly
will be toffee apple macarons,
and hard-boiled peanut sweets.
-Do you like spiders in real life?
-No.
Everyone thinks I would
because of the way I dress.
Because I look Gothic.
-I actually am quite scared of spiders.
-Yeah.
-They're not my biggest fear.
-What's your biggest fear?
Well, the same as any musician,
child prodigies.
-Child prodigies?
-Aye.
[laughing]
Good answer.
Put that in Room 101.
[Syabira] This is my gingerbread dough
for the lantern.
[Noel] Whatever the bakers
choose to build their lanterns from…
I'm making gingerbread.
I'm bringing cinnamon,
allspice, ginger, nutmeg.
…not only must it be delicate
and delicious to eat…
[Janusz] It contains almond flour.
But I've added some almond extract
just for extra kick.
[Noel] …but when suspended,
sturdy enough to hold their treats too.
A lot of people use gingerbread
because it's nice and strong.
I prefer working with sugar cookie,
it's got high sugar content,
so it makes it quite firm.
[Dawn] This is like a gingerbread.
But it's using carbon black cocoa powder,
which bakes coal black.
So it gives you a head start, really,
when you're trying to do a black cat.
[laughs]
[Matt] Dawn will construct
her ferocious feline
filled with monster macarons
and raspberry jelly eyeballs
by carefully joining her
two baked biscuit domes
to create one seamless sphere.
[Dawn] I need to make it meet.
So it's important to not cut corners
and just take whatever time you need.
It's not the neatest, but should be okay.
[Syabira] That's biscuits in.
[Noel] As the bakers' lanterns
start to hit the heat…
[Dawn] Bake well.
[Noel] …in a bid to stand out
from the crowd…
[Sandro] I'm melting some chocolate
so I can make a chocolate sphere.
[Noel] …Sandro's chosen
to avoid the oven altogether.
I think I'm the only person
using chocolate.
I'm a rebel by nature.
[Noel] Sandro will transform
his chocolate sphere
into a skull-encrusted disco ball
containing no less than
five different treats,
including chocolate orange palmiers,
nutty orange Florentines
and chilli chocolate fudge cookies.
You know,
you only have to do two sweets.
I know, but I'm trying to impress here.
-[Sandro chuckles]
-How many skulls you making?
-About 200 skulls.
-What?
-200?
-[Paul] Wow. Good luck, Sandro.
-Thank you.
-I thought you was going to be doing it
with, like, actual skulls.
I did try,
but I got kicked out of the graveyard.
-[sighs]
-[Sandro] I know.
-Next time. Yeah. [chuckles]
-Next time, please.
[Noel] I'm such a fan.
I mean, I just loved you
in Jason and the Argonauts.
Bakers, you are halfway through.
Oh, my gosh, halfway through.
It's a real pleasure
to work with you guys.
The biscuits are done.
[Syabira] I'm taking it out from the oven.
[Matt] Before the bakers
can start to construct their lanterns,
they must allow their biscuit
too cool and firm up.
-[sighs]
-[Kevin] It's a bit well done.
It'll be covered in chocolate ganache,
so you won't see that it's over-baked.
I just hope It doesn't
taste over-baked as well.
-[Noel] But they can't stop for a second…
-Cookie time.
…as they still have
sweet treats to create.
I'm adding some espresso powder.
I'm also going to add cayenne pepper.
Whoo! A whole lot of heat.
-It is Halloween.
-It's going to be a cricket truffle.
So the powdered cricket
tastes a bit more savoury,
which is contrasting
to white chocolate and pistachios.
[Noel] Powdered crickets. The insect?
-They rub their legs together.
-[Janusz] They do.
-Do you rub your legs together?
-[both laughing]
I do rub my legs together.
And I used to jump a lot,
but not so much now.
[Matt] While Janusz hopes to hit the mark
with his creepy-crawly confectionery…
[Maxy] I am making brownie truffles
and pumpkin macarons.
[Matt] …Maxy's going for cute and cuddly.
I'm sort of basing it
on my childhood memories of Halloween,
so it's not gonna be too gory. [chuckles]
[Noel] As well as monster brownie truffles
and pumpkin spiced macarons,
Maxy will make meringue ghosts
and tuile biscuit bats.
But with so many elements to bake,
her orange and cinnamon
shortbread lantern is yet to hit the oven.
[Maxy] Just rolling out my biscuit dough.
I really need to get these baked
as soon as possible.
Yeah, I've got quite a lot to do.
[Matt] This is the ultimate juggling act.
I'm just making the Florentines
and melting some more chocolate
for the skulls.
[Matt] Not only must the bakers ensure
every texture is spot on…
These are hazelnuts.
I've done Florentines before,
and I just found that
they're not nutty enough.
Yeah. You got the chewiness,
you got the crunch.
[Dawn] Just started on the jelly eyeballs.
[Matt] …the judges will demand
perfectly balanced flavours
across the bakes too
[Dawn] This is raspberry flavouring.
You need to go really carefully with it.
If you put too much in,
it will be hideous.
This is the mummy biscuits.
It's orange shortbread biscuits
with truffle.
I just like the combination
of white truffle and orange.
It's weird, but this is the time
to try all the weird combination flavour
and see what the judges think.
Do you like it? Do you not like it?
[Noel] Syabira's not
the only one taking a risk.
[Abdul] I'm now making my date balls.
It's rose water that's going in.
[sniffs] You can already smell it.
It smells really nice.
[Noel] But not content
with one contentious flavour…
-[Abdul] I'm making brandy snaps.
-[Noel] …Abdul is doubling down.
[Abdul] I'll dip them in
matcha white chocolate,
which is a bit risky
because the judges don't like matcha.
[Matt] Abdul will add almond nails
to his matcha-dipped brandy snaps
to create witch's fingers.
While his rosewater and spiced date balls
will become witch's eyes,
both encased in a gingerbread lantern.
[Abdul] I'm trying to multitask over here.
I'm trying to make the brandy snaps
and my date balls.
I think I'm running a bit behind schedule,
actually, about ten minutes.
[Noel] Bakers, you have half an hour left.
Oh, I think your family's here.
Oh, yeah. I invited 'em down
to meet Paul and Prue.
That's my aunty Jean in the red.
[zombies groaning]
[Maxy] I'm just multitasking,
trying to do so many things at once.
It's gonna be quite tight.
[Syabira] This is a Frankenstein finger.
I'm using classic traditional
Malaysian peanut cookies.
Peanut is definitely
a hero flavour for this one.
Erm, what have I got left to do?
Bake the choux pastry spider legs,
glaze the macaron shells,
finish peanut boiled sweets. [exhales]
-You're doing five things?
-Three so far have been done.
And I've got just two to do.
I am on track. Got the Florentines done.
They're quite thick,
so I'm gonna call them Florentine cups
'cause if I don't, Prue's gonna say,
"Oh, it's a bit thick for a Florentine."
-[Matt] Feeling the stress?
-Yeah, I'm definitely feeling the stress.
What are these gonna be?
They're little monsters.
-Wow. They're massive.
-You're working fast, aren't you?
[laughs] I sort of have to.
I've got thousands of things to do.
-Really?
-Yeah.
[Syabira] This is
the raspberry jelly worm.
I want that bite, the chew,
everything that gummy worms gives you.
These are the fingers.
That's the final piece of the puzzle.
Okay. Assembly.
So now I have to put the lantern together,
put the sweets in,
decorate that with popcorn.
If I'm watching a horror movie,
I would definitely go for popcorn.
But I would buy it
in the supermarket. [chuckling]
[Dawn] This is the backs of the eyeballs,
so I'm just putting a bit
of melted chocolate on.
How's it all going?
Tried to do too many things,
and I've run out of time.
I've gotta join this together,
but it's extremely wonky-looking.
[Kevin] I'll take off the rough edges
and it'll pop together.
[Dawn] I've got to just see
if I can make it meet.
[sighs]
Oh, God.
There's some gaps, but what can you do?
[Abdul] I am flattening the tops
just to make sure that it lies flat.
What I don't want is,
it's going to be all wonky.
[Syabira] I'm coating this with chocolate,
like a texture of a spider skin.
-[Sandro] That looks good, Syabira.
-Thank you, Sandro.
[Sandro] That is
a perfect ball right there.
I plan to completely cover
the entire ball with skulls.
[Maxy] This just isn't sticking.
[Dawn] We're struggling. Just gonna make
some buttercream really quickly.
I need options, at the moment.
It's very dodgy.
[clattering]
[Sandro] Ah, it cracked!
That's a big old crack right there.
What crack?
Bakers, you have 15 minutes left.
I'm gonna pipe the centre
of these macarons.
The sweet peanuts
just need to come out of the mould.
And then I need to ganache
the spider and put it together.
[laughs]
It's gonna break.
[Dawn] This isn't going to be
hanging on anything.
It'll be hanging by a thread.
Oh.
-[Kevin] Oh, these are so sketchy.
-[Sandro] These smell gorgeous!
Flake, lamination…
A bit chewy.
[Maxy] It's falling apart.
[clicks tongue] Oh.
Oh, man alive. [chuckles]
[Sandro] I'm cutting through
to make the hole.
I'm really trying.
I think I need a drill.
[Syabira] Where are you, switch?
Oh, yeah.
I don't know whether to
be shocked or turned on.
-I don't know what's going on here.
-[both laugh]
If I could just get it to hold together,
I can get the eyes on, at least
It's not gonna hang.
[inhales sharply] It's not going to hang.
-It's okay. Just breathe. Breathe.
-Yeah.
[exhales]
[Janusz] It's popcorn
with white chocolate.
[Matt] Ooh! Look at those!
Are they moustaches?
No. They're supposed to be spider legs.
[Sandro] Disco ball.
Wow!
Is it spooky enough?
[Dawn] Come on, stick.
Bakers, you have one minute left.
[Janusz] Time to hang you, babes.
[grunts]
Get off the board.
[sighs]
Oh, so sticky.
I decided to cut the Florentines in half,
because they won't go in as a whole.
[Dawn] It won't hang, so… Oh, my God.
Oh, cripes, man.
Bakers, your time is up.
[sighs]
Please step away
from your Halloween showstoppers.
That is shocking. [chuckles]
[Sandro] Well done, everyone.
This is wicked.
Syabira, get out! That looks amazing.
[sighs]
Man alive.
It's like a horror movie itself.
[Maxy] I can't look at it.
[hesitates] I… It looks like an--
-Oh, you're digging deep here.
-No, no, no.
[both laughing]
[eerie cackling]
[Matt] It's judgement time for
the hanging Halloween lanterns.
Sandro, would you like to
bring up your Hanging lantern?
Need a hand?
-[Sandro] Should be fine.
-Not with those guns.
[Sandro chuckling]
[Paul] It looks fantastic.
This is something
that you could buy in a supermarket.
[Prue] The skull ball is just amazing.
But the treats are all a bit big
to go in your lantern.
They are indeed.
There is Florentines, but halved.
[Paul] Okay,
-Wow.
-[Matt] There you go.
[Paul] They are as well.
That looks like solid caramel.
[Sandro laughing] Oh, my God.
-[muffled] It's a bit thick.
-[laughing]
Florentines taste amazing, just too thick.
[Prue] Okay, what about
the chocolate fudge cookies?
There's coffee and chilli.
Bit of coffee, bit of chilli, yes.
-Yeah.
-Oh.
[Sandro laughs]
I just found the trick in this lot.
-[Prue] Yes.
-[Paul] That's far too potent.
Wow. [coughs]
[Prue laughing] It is, really.
Can't eat anything else,
won't be able to taste anything else.
It's clever. The box is very neat as well.
[Prue] And I love the popcorn
and the eyes look really well made too.
Right.
[Paul] Let's try the biscuit first.
The biscuit has a lovely almond flavour.
[Paul] Lovely. Quite short as well.
There's trick truffles.
This is the one with the cricket flour?
And a whole cricket inside as well,
for a crunch.
[all laughing]
Just casually threw that in there.
It's a bit too sickly sweet for me.
[Prue] You should have
had more crickets in there.
The crickets have got
quite a nice savoury flavour.
Would've balanced it better.
[Janusz] Next you've got pumpkin spice.
Hmm. Over-spiced.
[Prue] Which is a pity,
because I like the textures.
I'm just concerned about some
of your flavours going wayward.
[Prue] Mmm.
Shame.
What happened to the lid?
Unfortunately, a zombie
came into the tent, and smashed it.
[laughter]
[Matt] We saw them, actually.
-[Maxy] Yeah.
-They are Noel's family though.
[Paul] It's a bit of a mess,
but it is hanging.
[Prue] I like the biscuit.
It's not too sweet, and it's very orangey.
The bake's got a nice crunch to it.
-Almost shortbread-like. Right.
-[Prue] Give it a whack.
The treat's pumpkin spiced macaron.
-[Prue] It's delicious macaron.
-Thank you.
[Prue] Soft in the middle,
crunchy outside.
And just the right amount
of pumpkin spice.
[Maxy] I also made brownie monsters.
Chocolatey, nutty. Extremely dense.
You couldn't have too many of them.
They're very rich. Tasty, but they are
massive for what you need.
If they'd been tiny,
the denseness wouldn't have mattered.
[Paul] The lantern looks neat as a pin.
Well-constructed.
Seems pretty solid. Shall we have a taste?
-Softer than I thought it would be.
-[Abdul] Okay.
I think it could have been baked
a little bit longer.
But the flavour is delicious.
-Are you ready?
-[Abdul chuckles] It might be ready.
-Yeah.
-[Prue] Right.
-[Noel] Again.
-[Matt laughs]
[Noel laughing]
Dramatic. [laughs]
Oh, that's so satisfactory, I tell you.
All right, so we've got witch's fingers.
Brandy snaps covered
in matcha white chocolate.
Lovely flavour with the matcha.
I'm not normally a great matcha fan,
but I think that is perfect.
It's nice and thin
and the almond is delicious.
-Right. This is the dates.
-[Abdul] Yes, the date ball inside.
The texture is good,
but all I'm getting is rose water.
-Okay.
-It's too strong.
If you'd pull that back a bit,
allow all the other flavours,
the pistachios to come through
the dates to come through,
I think you would have
been onto something.
But it's just overwhelming.
-[Prue] Well, it's quite scary.
-[Noel] Really scary.
-But it's very messy.
-[Paul] Okay.
Do your worst.
[Noel] Go on, Prue, give it some.
[Matt] Hey!
[Prue] Is it gingerbread?
[Kevin] No, it's sugar cookie
with orange and five-spice.
Ganache is delicious.
Biscuits, lovely and crisp.
-[Paul] Eating the macron?
-[Prue] Mmm-hmm.
Very sweet, but good flavour.
It's a bit crispy, though.
You want it to be a bit chewy inside.
They weren't my strongest macarons.
-[Prue] What's this made of?
-[Kevin] Butterscotch with salted peanuts.
-[Paul] Sweetness rather than flavour.
-Yeah.
And it needs to be finished properly.
Something with the nuts
sort of hanging out.
-[Noel laughs]
-I think it's all right.
[all snickering]
[chuckles]
[Matt] Normally Prue's territory,
saying things like that.
-[laughs]
-[Paul] Erm, the whole thing
just needed more time, more effort
'cause each bit is not perfect.
Mmm-hmm.
[Dawn] It may not hang. You can try.
-Oh, please.
-[Sandro] Yay!
-[applause]
-[Syabira] Hey!
Erm, it's a bit messy, isn't it?
Yes, it is.
The two halves aren't perfectly together,
but the general idea is impressive.
[Paul] Let's look inside.
Well, that worked.
It's black cocoa powder biscuit.
It's got a bit of cardamom as well,
but only a very small amount.
[crunching]
-[Prue] Very hard.
-Can't really taste anything.
Oh, okay.
It's nice and thin, which is just as well,
because it is rock hard.
[Paul] Now, my issue with the macarons,
they're a little bit too simple.
I wanted to do
a lot more detail on the face.
-That's just chocolate ganache?
-[Dawn] Yeah, with a bit of brandy.
-Again, that's quite simple.
-Yes, yes.
Chewy in the middle, shiny on top.
-Good.
-[Paul] Hmm.
Eyes.
[Prue] The jelly eyes
are really beautiful.
'Cause the jelly is unsweetened,
it's just texture,
but you do get the chocolate.
I just think it's all a little bit,
dare I say, basic?
I think it looks amazing.
I mean, really stunning.
Even down to the green light
coming from the mouth.
It is astonishing to look at,
and everything
is very neatly and delicately done.
That's unbelievable.
Your dark chocolate is bitter enough
to work really nicely
with the ginger biscuit itself,
which is exceptionally crunchy.
-Do you want to smash this one, Prue?
-[Prue] Yeah.
[Matt] Whoa!
-Whoa!
-[Paul] And it's still holding.
[Prue] Sinister finger.
Peanut biscuit's lovely.
Crumbly, the peanut kick is just perfect.
[Prue] Beautiful.
-So this is orange…
-And white truffle.
Cream cheese filling.
Mmm. Oh.
-Too much truffle.
-Oh.
-[chuckles]
-Why did you put truffle in there? Why?
It's not working?
[Paul] It had flavour, I'll give you that.
Syabira, you're off your head, honestly.
[all laughing]
Orange and truffle
does not go in a biscuit.
I accept they didn't like
the white truffle and an orange.
But it's fine. [chuckles]
[softly] Well done.
White truffle. [laughs]
It is very good comments,
and I'm very happy with it.
I don't want to jinx it,
but I was hoping for Star Baker this time.
[chuckles]
[Kevin] That went pretty much as expected.
I reckon
I'm not only in danger of going home,
I think it's a pretty foregone conclusion.
[Dawn] I'm bracing myself, to be honest.
I'm kind of, you know,
trying to get my head around the idea
that I might not come back next week.
[sighs]
[Matt] We learned something
from that showstopper
which is that
when Dame Prue has too much sugar,
we need to keep
that rolling pin away from her
because she'll whack anything in sight.
And will eat any creature.
Loves a cricket.
But I thought that, overall,
one person did better than anybody else.
-And I would say Syabira.
-[Prue] Yeah.
[Paul] When you look at the circumstance
we were coming into today…
'Cause she'd had a handshake
and won the technical.
-She won the technical.
-There you go.
She's unstoppable.
That's the long and short of it.
Does she have competition for Star Baker?
For the first time, no.
There's not gonna be a shock.
The ideas of all of the bakers were sound.
I just thought there was a little bit
of a rush job on some of these bakes.
I mean, Kevin's spider looked such a mess.
It's Kevin and Dawn in a bit of trouble.
Didn't think Dawn really did enough.
Coming into today, I would've said,
at the bottom of a very tight group,
it was Dawn and Kevin at the bottom,
and I think
we're still looking at those two now.
[Noel] Hello, bakers.
Luckily, I've got the great job
of announcing Star Baker this week.
And that person has had an amazing week.
Handshake, first in technical,
great showstopper.
Syabira.
-[applause]
-[Maxy exclaims]
[indistinct chatter]
Now I have the less fun job
of announcing who is leaving us.
And we obviously
are growing closer to all of you,
and so this person
will really be missed actually.
I'm sorry to say that the person
who is leaving us this week is…
Dawn.
That's fine.
[chuckles]
-[Dawn sniffles, sighs]
-Aw, poor Dawn.
-[Dawn chuckling]
-[Paul] Well done, Dawn. You did well.
Game over. [chuckles]
I really don't want to shed tears over it
because it's just been
the most amazing experience, really.
One of the absolute
best experiences of my life.
I can't wish for more than that.
You know, and there's a tear, look.
Don't let anyone see that.
My kids will be like,
"Mum doesn't do emotion.
What the hell's going on?"
[chuckles]
I'm really, really proud
of what I've done.
And I've had fun.
Such fun.
-Are you okay?
-I don't understand.
In my head, I was already gone.
And yeah, mmm…
I didn't expect that at all.
Now I'm in the top half of the bakers.
[chuckles]
That's another weird feeling.
I wasn't expecting that either.
And well done, Syabira.
What an amazing week.
-[Syabira] Thank you.
-[Noel] Amazing week.
I feel very happy and grateful
to get the Star Baker.
-It's a great feeling.
-You deserve it, girl. You deserve it.
But that's a scary place to be, honestly,
because the only way is going down.
So I'll try to maintain it. [laughing]
-I'm gonna miss you.
-[Dawn] Brilliant.
I'm really sad to see Dawn go.
She's funny, and I love her.
[Matt] It's been lovely
having you in the tent.
-It's been a pleasure.
-[Matt] Oh, you're not a hugger.
-[Noel] Not a hugger?
-[Matt] Remembered that too late.
-[laughter]
-[Dawn] Ease up on the hugging.
Group hug! Let's…
[laughs] Let's kill Dawn.
[laughter, indistinct chatter]
[closing theme music playing]